now let's catch up with some of the
day's other news now and here major
restrictions on travel between the uk
and india will come into effect from
friday after the government placed the
country on the so-called
travel red list covered cases in india
are soaring following the emergence of a
new variant there which has
also been detected here the health
secretary made the announcement this
afternoon shortly after the prime
minister cancelled a trip
to india that was due to start later
this week
after studying the data and on a
precautionary basis
we've made the difficult but vital
decision to add india to the red list
this means anyone who is not a uk or
irish resident or a british citizen
cannot enter the uk if they've been in
india
in the previous 10 days uk and irish
residents and british citizens who've
been in india in the past 10 days before
their arrival
will need to complete hotel quarantine
for 10 days from the time of arrival
these rules will come into force at 4 00
am on
friday that was the health secretary a
little earlier in the commons in a
moment we'll speak to sky
salier chaudhary who's in bolton but
first let's go to our chief political
correspondent john craig
who is in westminster and john
i guess with this surge in cases in
india
this was inevitable both the
cancellation of the trip
and uh india going on the red list
it's not a huge surprise and uh a lot of
mps have been saying actually this
should have happened a little a little
earlier more quickly
mr hancock was saying that uh they
detected
103 cases of this indian variant
he said the vast majority have links to
international travel
and have been picked up by our testing
at the border this was one of two major
announcements by uh
mr hancock when he was making a common
statement this afternoon
the second was the government's going
is ramping up plans as he put it for a
booster shot to ensure the
covid19 vaccines stay ahead of the virus
now
he said that um we've already procured
enough vaccine doses
to begin booster shots later this year
and
they're going to be working with the
current vaccine supplies and new
suppliers
like the cure vac partnership to work
out which vaccines will be effective as
a booster shot
and he talked about specifically
designing vaccines for
uh variants of concerns such as the
south african
variants now of course the announcement
about the
indian indian red list
move came hours after the prime minister
confirmed what many of us suspected that
his trip to uh
uh india big trade trip with all sorts
of trade deals he wanted to do
post-brexit due a week a week today
next week that's off this was the prime
minister confirming that today
narendra modi and i have uh have
basically come to the conclusion that
very sadly i won't be able to
uh to go ahead with the trip i do think
it's only sensible uh
to postpone given what's happening uh in
india the
the shape of the pandemic uh there we're
gonna we're gonna be going back and the
relationship between the uk
and india is of huge importance and i'll
be talking to narendra modi on promise
modi
on monday we'll be doing we're trying to
do as much as we can
virtually
well the cancelling of this india trip
uh begs questions what about some of the
other big international uh
events the prime minister's due to take
place to part in
later this year there's the g7 summit
down at a hotel down in cornwall
is that going to go ahead as planned uh
with all the
international travel involved in that
and then of course the cop 26 uh
summit on the environment climate change
due to happening glasgow later in the
year
now the copper president that's alex
sharma former cabinet minister
insisted in the commons the other day it
would go ahead
in person with everybody coming into
glasgow for that
but there are some doubts about that as
well whilst there are all these variants
in places like south africa
and india some of these big
international diplomatic gatherings
there must be some doubts
about some more of those too yeah
everything uh
moving uh quite fast uh thanks very much
john let's go to bolton celia chowdhury
so
what's the reaction there to india being
added to the red list i i assume
people thought that it was expected
yes well some people might have been
taken by surprise because of course if
they're
planning to travel after friday back
into the uk from
visiting india in the last 10 days they
wouldn't have known that
india was going to be put onto this red
list but as john craig mentioned there
cases have been soaring in india for
some time so it doesn't come as
a total surprise to many many people
what is concerning is not just the cases
but that particular variant which is
being called the indian variant
the body that looks into different
variants here in the uk
says that there are 182 cases of this
indian variant here in the uk
of which 162 were detected in the last
five weeks and that's what prompted
the health secretary matt hancock to
make this what he called as you heard a
difficult but
vital decision he said that they looked
at the characteristics of this variant
so things like transmissibility
and its resistance to treatment and
vaccines and
from that data they determined that this
is a variant of concern
and that the vast majority of those
cases here in the uk have come
as a result of international travel and
detected through border testing
and what that means uh is that if you're
a british
resident or a a british citizen or a uk
resident or irish resident
you can still come into the country but
you'd have to do that 10-day mandatory
quarantine at a hotel
if you're not falling into one of those
categories and you can't come into the
country at all and all of those
rules come into effect from friday 4am
and that takes the number of countries
on the uk's red list to 40.
okay saria thank you very much indeed